-Wiz!
-What up, baby?
-Welcome back.
You know, you've performed here
many times.
We've played games.
You're one of the greatest
guests we've ever had.
-Yeah, I always have fun here.
-But we've never had a chat.
We've never talked to each other
on the couch.
-Oh, not on the couch.
-So, I'm happy that you're here.
I want to get to know you and
talk to you about everything.
I know Salma Hayek Pinault
was just out here.
-Mm-hmm.
-And we learned
on "The Masked Singer"...
-Mm-hmm.
-...that was your
first celebrity crush.
Here's you, by the way...
-Yeah.
-...on "The Masked Singer."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yo.
[ Laughs ]
-Any certain movie from Salma?
-"Dusk Till Dawn" was one of
my favorite ones.
And then, when she was in
"Desperado," as well.
-Oh, she just crushes, right?
-Yeah, she --
-Did you get say hi?
-Yeah, I got to say hi.
-You did?
-Mm-hmm.
-Okay. That's what
I'm talking about, right?
[ Laughter ]
-It was awesome.
'Cause, like, she ate somebody
in "Dusk Till Dawn,"
so she didn't eat me
in real life.
-No, yeah, you didn't --
She didn't --
She didn't do it.
[ Laughter ]
You have a hobby of yours
that I wanted to ask you
a question about.
I follow you on the socials.
-Mm-hmm.
-And this is you, and you said
you "Made a banger tonight,"
which I'm assuming
you recorded a song.
-Yep.
[ Laughter ]
-You said, "About to watch ASMR
and catch some zzz's."
-Yep, yep.
-So, you watch --
ASMR is -- that's,
like, when people go
up to the microphone
and make noises.
-Yeah, it's really,
really soothing.
Like, everybody
has their own triggers.
And I got my own triggers,
as well, so, yeah.
-What is your --
what's your best --
what's the --
-I like hair noises.
Like, I like getting
my hair played with.
So, I just watch --
[ Laughter ]
-People like it, too.
Apparently, it's a thing.
[ Laughter, scattered cheers ]
I didn't know the audience
was into this.
-Yeah, I watch people play with,
like, mannequins and, like,
just rub their hair and part it
and all that stuff.
[ Laughter ]
It's soothing.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-That's soothing right there.
So, you got someone playing
with a mannequin head?
-Yeah, yep.
[ Laughter ]
-And you go right --
you go right to sleep?
-I'm asleep in three minutes.
[ Laughter ]
-I love that.
You made news
a couple weeks ago, buddy,
when you said that you
smoked weed with Michael Phelps.
-Yeah, that was awesome.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-I mean, he's an Olympian.
He's a gold medalist.
He is the best swimmer in the --
You said that
he had Aquaman lungs.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I think he might've had
better lungs than Aquaman, bro.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-Champion, bro.
-Yeah, but what
made you go, like,
"Oh, he's got Aquaman lungs?"
I mean, he just --
-Because the way -- he hit the
joint a little bit differently.
He hit it like --
like a gold medalist would.
-Really?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Did he just, like,
inhale the whole thing?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It disappeared after --
-It disappeared.
[ Laughter ]
He just kept inhaling, and then
he just sucked it all in there.
You're like, "Wow."
And then he exhaled
and went back in your hand?
Yeah.
But you have your own line
of stuff, right?
-Yeah, yeah.
It's called Khalifa Kush.
-Khalifa Kush?
-Uh-huh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And did he handle
the Khalifa Kush?
Could he handle it?
-Yeah, he did.
Anybody can handle
the Khalifa Kush.
I recommend it for non-smokers,
first-time smokers,
or O.G. smokers.
We got flower, we got vapes,
we got edibles
in all select markets.
We're available in Michigan,
Pennsylvania, Maryland,
Florida, Arizona.
And we just released
another strain.
It's called Khalifa Mints.
It's Khalifa Kush
mixed with menthol,
and we've got more strands
coming out next year, as well.
-Gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
-Crushing it, buddy.
Crushing it.
-And I smoked K.K.
before I said that.
[ Both laugh ]
-Oh, my God.
Look at this guy.
Can you explain who this guy is?
That's you.
-Yeah, that's me.
-Yeah.
Now, what are you doing here?
You're in a movie?
-Yeah, I'm playing
George Clinton.
Yeah, yeah.
-I love George Clinton.
Look at this.
-Yeah, yep.
-That's the real George Clinton.
-Parliament Funk-- yeah.
-Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Dr. Funkenstein.
"Spinning Gold."
Is it tough to play somebody
who is alive?
Did you talk to George?
-Yeah, we -- I talked to him.
His grandkids
were actually on set, too.
So, it was really cool to, like,
vibe off of them and just hear,
you know, stories or...
-Oh, my gosh.
-...even just them telling me,
like, how proud he would be,
like, you know,
seeing me do the role.
So it was official.
It was fun.
-That's pretty cool.
-Yeah, it was cool.
-I'm looking forward to that.
That's coming out next year.
-Yeah, I am, too.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's talk about
the new album, bud.
-Yes, sir, yes, sir.
-It's out.
"Multiverse."
-Uh-huh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They love it.
"Multiverse" has nothing to do
with Marvel, by the way.
-No.
This is -- This is like
"Multiverse" because --
-It's like the multi--
It's like finding myself
in different dimensions.
Or just taking you
on a journey with me.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yep.
-Because I was thinking, like,
maybe because you're versatile.
-Yeah, very versatile.
Exactly.
I don't like to do
one style of music,
so I want to create
an experience for people
that they can just have from me,
you know?
-Is there any music
you don't like?
-No, I love all music.
I love pop, rock, country,
reggae, funk --
-You like country?
-Yeah, I love country.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you like country
'cause of the lyrics?
-Yeah, I like the writing, like,
how it just invites you
into the song.
Like, before
the second verse is over,
you know how to sing
the whole song.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
There is an art to that.
-It's really clever.
-There is an art to that.
-Yeah, I love that.
-You started rapping
when you were 9 years old.
-Uh-huh.
-Now you have a son who is 9.
-Yep, Sebastian.
-And how's Bash?
-He's really good, man.
He's a genius.
There's times
where I leave the house,
and I'll come back home,
he's like, "Hold on, Dad.
I'm recording my song
right now."
He's, like, in the studio,
already doing his thing.
-He's in the studio?
-Yeah, yeah.
-I thought you were gonna say
he's in his bedroom.
-No, no.
[ Laughter ]
I have a studio --
I have a studio in the house.
So, he goes in there, and
he bosses my engineer around.
And he's cool as heck, yo.
-Wow.
-It's really cool to see.
-So, we have to look forward
to your son maybe coming --
-For sure.
-Yeah?
-He'll be on the couch next.
-That's what
I'm talking about, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wiz, Wiz Khalifa, you're
performing for us tonight.
What song are you gonna do
for us tonight?
-I'm gonna be doing
"Memory Lane."
-"Memory Lane."
That's what I'm talking about.
Wiz Khalifa, everybody!
"Multiverse" is out now.
"Memory Lane" when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.